[Music]
[Applause]
[Music] [Applause]
[Music]
happy birthday to you
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
cardi B is ringing in a new decade
yep the rapper celebrated her 30th
birthday on Tuesday first a small
get-together with family and a few
friends
[Applause]
[Music]
and in true cardi fashion she also went
all out with a burlesque theme Soiree I
want to see sexiness that's going to be
a very sexy show it's going to be
amazing it's going to be extravagant
like hello Carly's throwing it
[Music]
check out Cardi's sister Hennessy next
to the birthday girl who arrived at The
Bash in a fiery red Ensemble oh yes
honey definitely on theme for Cardi's
dirty 30 Cabaret guilty the venue poppy
nightclub in Los Angeles which was
filled with Cardi's famous friends and
everyone is going to be there inside
Chloe and Hallie Bailey rubbed elbows
with the likes of Tiffany haddish Chance
the Rapper and Tyga also snagged invites
and of course Cardi's hubby offset was
by her side celebrating her special day
before the extravagant Gathering offset
shared a sweet post for his lady love
writing quote happy birthday my
beautiful wife thank you for having my
beautiful kids love you alongside a
carousel of photos he gifted her
beautiful Arrangements of red roses and
petals scattered throughout their home
thank you baby daddy
thank you
and it seems a birthday is not the only
thing they're celebrating cardi is
making history as the first female
rapper with two songs bodak yellow
dance I make money move and I like it
[Music]
certified 11 times Platinum I gotta see
it to believe it her label Atlantic
Records sent her pink and red roses in
honor of her big moment thank you so
much it's giving [ __ ] we love you but
we won the album right now hoe we want
to make some money I'm gonna make us
some money I'm gonna make us some money
clearly cardi is feeling the love on her
big day so these were Atlantic
these were my husband so thank you
offset per
haha
[Music]